Jacket. And I just took it out of the dryer.
Has been washed and dried.
I got it from the TikTok shop.
There's a link right here.
My favorite part is that you can button the bottom pieces,
the bottom. Bottom three,
and make it look like a pullover,
but it's not. It's still just,
you know,
you don't have to go through all that trouble to take it on and off.
It's like fleece. It's not super thick,
but it's not thin at all, so it's definitely nice.
You can definitely wear it, like,
under a jacket if it's really cold.
You could wear it alone if it's just a little chilly.
And it's got a ton of pockets,
and. Yeah,
it's just a cute little. It's like my Rich Mountain mom sweater.